T-SERIES
I challenged you to a battle to the death *ehh*
Why have you not accepted my challenge?"
Are you scaAaAred?
T-SERIES?
cAUSE IM NOT *YEET*
You think you can beat me in subscribers?
Maybe you can,
but you cannot beat me, IRL
Man up ):<
And accept my challenge, T-Series (ง ͠° ͟ل͜ ͡°)ง
Until then, smash subscribe
Smash  s u b s c r i b e
That being said, I had a completely original idea for a video today
Twitch Perfectly Timed Moments
You seen these videos?
You heard about this? Hilarious. Okay?
It's basically... Streamers. They sit all day and all night playing video games
W h a t   a   b u n c h   o f   l o s e r s
And then eventually, something funny happens
Because, not because they themselves are entertaining...
*weird laugh* Coming from me.
It's a kinda thing you don't really laugh at
It's a kinda thing you just go-   That's funny
So let's react to that today everybody *laugh*
I'm the hype man everybody,
I know how to make stuff interesting
"They'll destroy you Marcus"
"You gotta go!" :,(
You gotta go -"Get outta here!"
* WTF am I going to do?*
Go?
*Pewds and streamer and me laughing*
Yes, Detroit: Become Human.
The Playstation 4 heard the call
Alright, I'm out
Nova: There was-There was some in here like uhh
Like obviously we sh*t on
But like, it seems like- I just realized,
This is me watching Nova, watching some other guy, watching Miley Cyrus.
2018 everybody
Nova: Everybody else enjoys them, so I guess they just, they would run with the narrative that, y'know, that everybody- everybody enjoyed it
Instead of uhhh keeping us in there to be like
This video is *beep* *beep*
I f*cking hated that song
AHHAH , NEVERMIND, NEVERMIND
THEY KEPT IT IN [INSERT LAUGH]
That's good, that was a wholesome funny clip.
See, how dare you question the integrity of the Fine Brothers, Nova? Disgusting.
Can't believe, anyone would do that
The speculations with no grounds on them. Alright,
you know what?
This is actually pretty fun
I'm actually enjoying this
Streamer: Why is this guy creeping as well?
Streamer: What are you creeping for? *Gasps*
He lived!
Streamer: I figured out why he was creeping. *laughs*
Huh
How bout dah? A funny video. That was funny [Was it?].
Look, she shoots it.
And he gets up!
He sa.. she saved his life!
You know what maybe I was a little harsh. These are actually quite enjoyable.
Let's keep watching
Smash like if you enjoy this video right now
Streamer: saying how nice the cars were....
Streamer: Oh look at this kid just on his bicycle. Kids don't d - *laughing*
Now that's a savage nine-year-old right there
Is that Jameskii?
*Roblox death sound*
*Best laugh ever*
Jesus Christ
That was perfect timing though, I gotta admit. Wait, I gotta see it again
*Oooof*
*laughter*
Why?
I feel like the people that watch these streams they know what the trigger is and they'll use it at the perfect time
Streamer: That's kinda sad
Streamer: *jazz music plays*
Streamer:Though impressive that in the 200 years they didn't- like neither of them fell off the pier. Pewds: So sad... That music
Streamer: Until... *laughs*
Streamer: Until Dogmeat walked past
Oh that's funny actually. I thought they were glued or something.
Streamer: You can buy cough syrup with other
Streamer: without ahhhmmmmmm
Streamer: What do you call it
Donation sound: We call him Bruce U
[Ugandan Bruce Lee]
That was such a perfect moment
such relatable, awesome-sauce everybody
Smash like if you thought that was epic
Game: -dice and I want a 6
Okay
Game: Yeah
Ohh
You got a key
Game: And I want a two
Whoaaa!
Oh come on
Another key
Roll it again and I want to see a 3
Whoaaaaa!
Criken's reaction is so good, look at him
Roll it again and I want to see a 3
Whoaaa!
I have no idea what's going on [me neither]
I feel so old watching this
What all these kids video games that they're playing I never seen them
I don't play games, I just react to other people playing games , what? What's so weird about that?
blom blom
Anomaly: *Swedish accent* That timing with the oof! xdxdxd
That's my donation sound
Anomaly is the most Swedish-sounding person ever. I don't know how he still has that accent.
He sounds like me when back in 2012 or something
That timing with the OOF!
*mocking* That timing with the ooof!
That is my donation sound
I can't even do it. What happened to me huh?
What happened to me? I remember who I used to be- *Kaz: "Why are we still here?"* Pewds: Why am I still here?
What's it gonna be?
Oh my god, people are just dying left and right
Game: We're losing civilians left and right commander
Oh *laughter*
I like that. I like that cause it wasn't perfect timing, it was just enough for you to go wha- nani?
That was good, I like that. I like that. Smash like if it made you laugh
This is honestly funny though. Like I'm having a good laugh
Hey it's another Forsen clip
Another Swedish dude
Apparently this is all Swedish people do. We just play games all day.
Oh really?
*oh really?*
You just died
Again. O M E G I L U L O M E G I L U L O M E G I L U L
You just died again. O M E G I L U L O M E G I L U L O M E G I L U L- Forsen: What the hell?
You just... died again, you just died again. O M E G I L[No I'm not typing that again]-
Give me a motivational speech
*slams table* AHHH
*Pewds Laugh*
Thanks brother
Game: You can thank me later
Okayyy, sorry
It was- That was awesome. It was almost like the game heard him
I thought you got ran over by a car
Pewds: Who plays PUBG still? Pathetic
*gets run over* OOH I- *laughter*
Pewds: God damn it
How do you get run over by a car there?!?
*last breath*
*Mario dying sound*
hehehAHAHA
Oh god
*laughter*
Okay that was good, okay? That was good.
Got me
First, the worst thing to say in a marriage proposal
Filthy Frank: STFU no one cares about your robot fan fiction
Okay
Vote for your favorite
Frankuuuu! Frankuuu why?
Why'd you leave us?
I just want him to come back for one video, just one video
Please, just for old time's sake. Please.
2016 YouTube. Before the bubble had burst
I remember talking to it about Brad like
How all this edgy content on YouTube was just everywhere
and it was a bubble which was waiting to burst
Maybe I was the needle in that thing
but I didn't- I didn't make the bubble, okay?
Alright, get some epic music
*loud music*
Did he just perfect-time himself?
I played that game
You play- you spend so much time doing nothing and then just something just happens out of nowhere. I get why he got so scared
but also
what an absolute soyboy
Dadatvchannel. Who gets scared at playing video games
*loud music*
hhehehehheheheheheheh
Ahhh that's a good reaction
It looks like himself as well
That's enough *clapsX2* perfect time moments for me for one day
That was pretty fun
Shoutout to everyone for letting me use your clips
[and to the caption authors too :)]
I'm sorry if I roasted you
ごめんなさい [It means "I'm sorry" in Japanese]
I'll link everyone in the description if you wanna check them out. Support
support each other on different platforms
I wonder if Brad has a perfect time
Brad Woto
I can't shout out everyone else
and not Brad
This is his most popular highlight. Okay
Now for... my feature film
Birds.
With the invention of the mobile phone, nobody's ever seen a bird.
But I'm here to show you an inside look at nature's flying, feathery furballs [Balls?]
Nobody over there, nobody over here
Oh. Home alone
and
awhoooooooooop
Don't look now, but there's a guy filming us
Oh really?
Yeah, right there
-Oh  -Wait don't look!
Oh I looked! Oh, I'm looking right at him!
Why? Why's he filming us?
I don't know
*InHaLe*
Brad. We need- we need a Brad- Birds 2. Please
That's Brad Woto everybody!
follow me on ig: @valous12 thanksss xoxo
Thank you very much for watching. See you guys tomorrow.
1 million likes for birds 2!!!
*place ad here*